hello everyone as Sara said my name is
Ben gable I am a developer advocate
working in games and I'm super excited
to be here today two reasons I used to
be an X indie game developer myself
before I joined Google as Sara was as
well and also I went to school at
DigiPen Institute of Technology over in
Redmond so Seattle is kind of my old
stomping grounds so kind of continuing
the flow is give me a lot of information
I'm gonna be going through it very kind
of quickly to stay on time so I'm here
to talk to you today about building an
awesome game in Android and really what
does that mean well you guys know how to
build awesome games it's all about
building a high-quality game in Android
you know Android is the largest mobile
operating system out there and that
means there's tons of people all around
the world they're gonna be playing your
game on different devices on different
versions of the OS and you know it's a
huge challenge and you want to make sure
that you're developing a super
high-quality game so that when somebody
picks it up on a certain device or a
certain version of Android they don't
have a bad experience because if they
have a bad experience could turn into
bad reviews or there could uninstall it
or not tell their friends about it so
it's super important to kind of consider
all the different places and ways that
people are going to be experiencing your
game on Android and really this breaks
down in two areas I'm going to talk
about today so the first two areas is
kind of like what's new in Android from
a technical perspective and kind of
water the new branch so there's a new
branch called Chrome OS they will talk
about a bit and the second part is going
to kind of touch more on you know as
Indies resources is you know having
resources to test and make sure that
your game is delivering a high quality
experience it's hard so I'm going to
talk about maybe some solutions you can
consider they'll hopefully make that a
lot easier for your guys so let's jump
in
so Android pee just came out a couple
months ago and one thing I wanted to
bring up before we jump into Android pee
is there was a new play requirement that
actually just yesterday you need to be
targeting API level 26 or above in order
to launch any new updates for your game
so if you weren't already aware of this
update
and you're planning on launching an
update soon you might have some extra
work to do so please be aware of that
but the bigger thing I wanted to bring
up is next year we have a new
requirement coming which is kind of more
relevant to game developers and that's
you'll need to ship a 64-bit version of
your game for whatever architecture
you're targeting so you know this is
something that you could have lots of
external dependencies on third-party
plugins or something or your game engine
you know you might have to consider
updating your game engine to support
64-bit build but as more and more 64-bit
only devices are going to be launched in
the Android ecosystem it's important to
make sure that games are available so
again kind of continuing the theme of
making sure that you're aware of all the
different kinds of flavors of devices
that people are going to be playing your
game on
so notches have come to the Android
ecosystem if you guys have seen pixel 3
I am personally not a notch guy but a
lot of people are so it's important to
consider that your game might be being
played on a Android device with a notch
so we've added a bunch of api's best
practices online and actually some
developer tools where you can simulate
notches on a device so I recommend that
you take a look at how your game is
running on a notch device and make sure
that the UI is not being cut off or
there's other rendering issues there
happening there notifications
notification channels are now compulsory
as of API level 26 so you'll need to
specify a specific channel for each of
one of your notifications and basically
what this lets users do is activate or
deactivate certain channels that they
maybe care about and also they can
customize the behavior of each one of
the notification channels so really what
this means for you guys is to think
about what kind of channels you're
putting your notifications in and not
spamming the user and kind of being
aware that people might be turning
things on and off as they upgrade to
Android p4 NDK there's been a bunch of
new stuff that I will kind of go over
briefly on basically the added api's for
neural networks and the j'ni shared
memory so that's that's a huge deal
super exciting we have now clang plus
plus is the default compiler for NDK
builds and Lib C++ is now the only STL
implementation that's
with the NDK so please be aware of that
and then also we've now got the L LD
linker as of r18 is available for
testing which will we've seen can
greatly speed up your link linker times
so you know sometimes building and
deploying is super slow so I recommend
you check that out as it could help you
speed up that process greatly okay some
other Android P features we've got a our
core Vulcan 1.1 support neural network
api's we've got a job scheduler for work
background workloads which should be
super interesting for super helpful for
some of you and also we've got a indoor
location API which you guys being Indies
come up with craziest ideas I'm sure
somebody will come up with an amazing
game idea at basis around that so
excited to see what you guys do with it
cool so now let's jump on to games on
Chrome OS so maybe a quick question how
many of you have used the Chromebook
before or yeah okay so some people and
how many of you were aware that your
android games can now run on Chromebooks
okay a few more but not a lot so this
would be exciting so if you didn't know
Android games can out run on Chrome OS
so you can see here on the right we've
got the pixel book which is a more
traditional laptop style device and just
announced was the pixel slate which is
coming out later this month as a tablet
with a detachable keyboard and Chrome OS
is as I said games can now run on Chrome
OS so your Android game is probably
running on Chrome OS right now and
there's probably people there asking to
play it or are already playing it the
biggest ass we've been getting from
users on Chromebooks is they want to
play games on it
and Google's putting a huge amount of
effort into kind of building out the
Chrome OS ecosystem so again kind of
going back to building a high quality
experience you might have users that are
playing on Chromebooks and should be
aware that they could be playing on
Chromebooks so this is a kind of a huge
new area of Android that presents a huge
opportunity to collect more users and
also play it in a way that for your game
for specific your gameplay design might
actually be a much better way to play it
so Ben you might be asking deploying and
testing and all these versions of
Android
or is already hard device fragmentation
is real I'm an indie dev I know how that
goes
how can we possibly support from us well
the good news is that most of it is
probably already done for you the Play
Store is the same on on Chrome OS and
mobile devices currently so if it's on
the Play Store right now it's probably
running on Chrome OS there's a few
permissions and stuff that if you're
asking for it listed is incompatible but
we can talk about that later
it's the same apk on both Chromebooks
and mobile device so there's no extra
libraries or other plugins you have to
integrate just works and as we've seen
you know a lot of times 90% of the time
the games work great but with that said
there are some key differences I'll
touch on in a moment so how does this
work basically on top of the Linux
kernel on Chromebooks you've got Chrome
OS and you've now got the Android
container so it's not a VM it's Android
running natively on top of the Linux
kernel it's the full version of Android
it's not a stripped down or special
version so anything that works on mobile
device works on Chromebooks so that
makes a lot easier for developers to
target and support it and moving forward
so you can see Android pee just hit the
canary channel for Chromebooks a couple
weeks ago moving forward all the major
releases of Android will also hit
Chromebooks and they'll be in basically
be in sync so again important to kind of
consider that this is happening so as I
mentioned there are some key differences
you should be aware of so first off you
get the bigger screen so more pixels to
render could you know look at
performance also you could look at UI
considerations you know you got all this
extra screen real estate space to take
advantage of default landscape
orientation so those of you with a
portrait style portrait default
orientation might want to take a look at
that if you don't do anything there
might be some giant ugly black bars
there that are no good on Chrome OS
dynamic resizing is the default so when
you launch any kind of Android app it's
in a window that can be dynamically
resized fortunately in the game world we
don't really deal with dynamic resizing
and a lot of game engines don't handle
that very well
so consider maybe disabling dynamic
resizing or just locking into fullscreen
and then kind of obviously the biggest
difference is now you've got a keyboard
in the case of the pixel book attached
to the device and as we see more and
more games kind of blurring the line
between you know consoles and PCs you've
got things like pub G fortnight the same
gameplay that's on PC is now coming to
Android obviously implementing keyboard
and/or mouse controls could be a huge
benefit to provide the best possible
game experience for your Android players
on that device so consider that also one
thing it's not listed here is that you
know a lot of mobile devices are ARM
based and a lot of developers don't ship
an x86 version a lot of Chromebooks are
x86 based so you should be aware that
you might see some performance
degradation due to the translation that
happens when you try to do an arm so an
arm apk will run on an x86 through
Houdini it's a translation layer but
you'll kind of get that overhead there
so if you can ship an x86 version you
should definitely take it and do that
so vainglory is a mobile for example
developed by super evil Megacorp they
implemented full skill bindings on for
their keyboard skill bindings and item
usage and they still left the
touchscreen controls in and they
actually told me they found an
interesting kind of hybrid approach
where you can tap the screen to select
enemy heroes much quicker than with a
trackpad and then use the keyboard to
kind of fire off skills and items so
they found a lot of their pro players
actually prefer that input method
compared to the one way or the other and
then Gameloft has developed asphalt 8
and recently asphalt 9 for Chromebooks
and you know on mobile they're just a
tilt and touch based control but on
Chromebooks they actually detect that
the keyboard is connected and allow you
full WASD and arrow key controls and
obviously on the bigger screen it looks
a lot better too they've got some great
graphics and the other interesting thing
that they found is that when they launch
asphalt 8 they found a 6x increase in
data active users and 9x increase in
monetization which kind of again speaks
to Chromebooks people want to play games
on them and I think this kind of speaks
to players are clamoring for it so one
other quick note
is that Linux is actually on Chromebooks
now too so there's a full debian VN VM
running on Chromebooks that you can
actually install Android studio you can
install steam it's not very fast yet
don't worry I tried but we're really
working on trying to improve
compatibility and speed of the Linux VM
so definitely check that out if you get
a chance cool so that was a quick
run-through of you know these big new
branches and areas of things that you
know users are going to be experiencing
in the Android ecosystem and you as game
developers should try to be aware of
these new features and these new kind of
devices that people are playing on and
try to target that and provide the high
quality experience now let's talk about
testing and how you can you know from
that aspect provide a high stable
performance no crashing fewer bugs so
we've got some tools we'll talk about
here and the first off in Android studio
3.3 you can now sample native C++
threads so for any app that is API level
26 or above you can do this so maybe a
raise of hands how many of you have
never ever left debug logging code in
production code when it shipped anybody
okay good because I was gonna call him a
liar so now if you've done something
like this
it might do something cool function
inside Android studio I can see that
might do something cool function is
doing something not very cool at all and
I can fix that
systrace is now coming to Android studio
it's not quite in Canary yet but it's
coming and basically systrace kind of
gives you a snapshot of how your game is
running on the Android in addition to
the Android system so you know you might
be using unity or unreal or have your
own kind of profilers that are happening
but they might not give you as much
detail about how your game is running in
terms of the rest of the system
processes so inside Android studio in a
bit you'll be able to see kind of this
whole view so you'll see up on the top
you've got the CPU time you've got your
different CPU cores you've got all your
threads display of all the threads that
are running and at the bottom you got
your call chart so there's a couple of
really useful
use cases for this that will hopefully
make debugging and profiling and
optimizing for Android much easier so
the first here as you can see that we've
highlighted this this thread and I don't
know if you can see if there's some red
red frames right there so they kind of
indicate that those are slow frames so
you can dig in and kind of see maybe
outside of your game why something might
be causing those slow frames and here
you can actually see on this we've
highlighted this thread you can see it's
jumping across the different CPU cores
which could be causing some performance
impact so you might consider setting
thread affinity for that specific thread
to kind of stay on one core and here we
can see that this is a very very
terrible frame it's taking a long time
but now inside a new studio you'll be
able to dig in and figure out why it's
so slow you can see down at the call
chart at the bottom there's ink multiple
calls to inflate which obviously is
inflating the frame time so super useful
tools that are is coming very soon that
we hope that you guys will kind of take
advantage of and hope it provides value
also a super exciting I think this is
the biggest thing is you'll be able to
basically instrument and provide your
own events for your game so you could do
things like set events around your
loading screens you could set events
around your shadow passes or other you
know areas of high intensity gameplay
where your performance is a problem
and basically that'll show up inside
systrace much more clearly and you'll
get be able to get those deep insights
that you need in order to optimize for
Android and in the future we're working
on adding more support around viewing
vsync events and timing around that so
there's some other things coming too for
games that will be announced early cool
and then one of the other tools I wanted
to bring up was gap it so gap it is
basically a it's our graphics API
debugger
it's basically lets you trace inspect in
or play all of your draw calls so for
example if you've got some weird
graphical bugs or maybe some
performances not as you expect you can
tray sample a portion of your gameplay
and go through all the frames all the
draw calls view things like models
textures Shea
basically view everything that the
system is doing to compose that frame so
it gives a lot of insight that you might
not be aware of to help debug issues
supports both OpenGL and Vulcan based
games so if you're doing either one you
should be covered and it runs on both
Windows and Mac cool so now let's talk
about game testing which you know we
know game testing on Android is hard all
these devices all these different
versions of the OS a lot of the
different a lot of the existing tools
are also not built around games so we've
kind of went on a quest we wanted to
find a solution that was easy to write
script since I have an IDE you could run
on your local device run it maybe on a
farm of devices in the cloud somewhere
simple to use and confident in the
results and we actually found a solution
being built by a Chinese game developer
called Neddy's called air tests and
basically what's it lets you what it
lets you do is test your production apks
with no instrumentation required you can
run it on your local device and it also
integrates with firebase test lab to
test it on the to run these tests on the
cloud so you can see here the IDE but I
actually got a video here that will kind
of go through it so you can see on the
right is your game and then in the
middle is kind of your script window and
as you play through the game like you
would normally it's writing a test
script for you so it's trying to do all
the things that you do on true doing and
basically what you can do is you can
write out this entire script you can
tell it to do things like click on
buttons assert that player models it
should be there are there move things up
and down they see anything that you
could do playing the game air test can
can also emulate it and then what you do
is you run the test and it actually
plays to your game each step gives you
all the output and for each step in the
test after it's done it'll give you a
report here we'll see in a second that
shows you the results of all those steps
so it'll show you what steps failed if
there's any warnings or errors it'll
give you a log of all the screenshots of
all of the different steps
so it's really useful to kind of maybe
do this for things like first time user
experience or a tutorial level or just
other kinds of boilerplate areas of your
gameplay that you might test at one
point and everything works fine you go
and you do a bunch more changes for a
couple more weeks and new features and
then you go back and everything's broken
so this is a great way of kind of
writing these tests and automating the
whole process that you don't have to do
it over and over and over again and kind
of underlying err test here is there's
two two frameworks at work there's air
test which is using image recognition
just looking at the pixels on the screen
and then if you want more integrated
testing or more kind of complex test
cases you can integrate pocos which is
basically it exposes the UI and object
hierarchy inside your game and there's
plug-ins for poco for unity Koko's and
other custom game engines so you kinda
have a - two flavors you can use depend
on how deep you want to integrate this
testing solution and the really
interesting thing here and kind of the
most exciting thing is that this all
integrates with firebase test lab so
what you can do you I guess those of you
that don't know what firebase test lab
is is it's basically a cloud of devices
there's physical and virtual devices
running all different kinds of the
Android OS and you can upload tests to
it and it will test your game for you
and give you reports and with air tests
you can basically build your test apk
you can upload it to firebase test lab
you can create a suite of these
automated tests that will then kick off
whenever you want there's actually a
command-line interface to hook into your
continuous integration so every time I
one of your developers pushes a change
it'll kick off these tests and select
which devices which versions of the OS
you want to target and it'll actually
give you a very detailed report that
shows you all the failures it shows you
all the system logs it'll actually give
you a video replay of your tests of your
game running so you can actually see and
verify that what you thought I was doing
is
being done and it actually gives you
performance data synched to the video so
you can see things like CPU time memory
usage network usage it's basically a QA
army at your fingertips so it's super
exciting and I think this is like one of
the biggest challenges for indie game
developers is that you don't have a lot
of resources to test your game you're
trying to build a game not necessarily
tested so being able to set up these
kind of automated tests and just have
them running over and over again again
make sure that you're kind of
maintaining that high quality bar and
delivering a great experience so here's
some links so for more information you
can find the ID at ear test the first
one and then we've got some github
projects and now let's talk about vitals
sera kind of briefly mentioned this but
vitals you know air tests and fire based
test lab are for pre-launch you know
development building new features
testing vitals is basically a way to see
you get actual data from devices that
have opted into the android vitals kind
of diagnostic system so you get actual
reports from actual user devices out in
the wild they're actually playing your
game so this is a huge deal and what you
know why we made this is that basically
found that 50% of once I reviews
mentioned stability and bugs right again
providing that great experience has a
really big impact on your rating which
impacts you know your success it's one
of the many ways that you any developers
kind of create success so it's important
and you might have seen this already
in your play console but you can go in
and you can look at your android vitals
report it'll give you kind of detailed
breakdown of all the different crashes
and all these kinds of other things that
vitals is monitoring for and some of the
ones that might be of interest to game
developer specifically obviously are
these are kind of the bad behaviors that
Android vitals test for so you've got
crash rates you've got ANR's
around battery you know as Android pee
has introduced a lot of new kind of
battery and power measuring tools for
the users so if your app or games if
your game is up at the top of this list
of like it's
that puts you in a dangerous territory
of potentially getting uninstalled or
you know used less so making sure that
you know you're not waking up the system
too often or you are don't have any
stuck way clocks when your app tries get
back grounded if you call on to things
like audio handles or stuff like that
your app your game won't be back around
it properly and it's continued to drop
our cool so let's recap real quick you
know I went through a lot of information
and really again it's kind of in these
it's developed it's providing a high
quality experience because that really
directly impacts the success of your
indie game in the hands of users so the
first two parts you know I kind of
talked about was you know consider these
consider where the users are going to be
playing what kinds of environments your
players are going to be playing your
game in so all these new Android P
devices that are go out there have these
new features maybe consider how you
might integrate those new features
consider that people will probably be
playing on Chrome OS moving forward and
that you should make sure that your game
runs great on Chrome OS and then the
second part you know is really again
once you ship a high-quality game
maintaining that quality bar so
profiling and optimize your game so it
runs great on as many devices as
possible I'm testing early and often and
using things like vitals to attack
production issues like quickly so all
these things kind of come together and
will allow you hopefully I hope you
found at least one thing in here that
will maybe help you guys kind of provide
the higher quality experience and kind
of take some load off
so you can do you know focus more on
building gameplay and the super awesome
kind of innovative features and some of
the more like boilerplate kind of game
quality type stuff hopefully there's
something in here that's useful to you
guys so thank you very much for your
time